تنضم معنا من القاهره عبر الهاتف الفنانه
القديره سهير رمزي اهلا بك السيده سهير
شرفتينا ونورتينا بوجودك معانا في رمضان
مساء الخير رمضان كريم الله اكرم ده انا
اللي سعيده بوجودي معكم يعني كل سنه وانتم
طيبين وكل سنه والساده المشاهدين طيبين
وقناه العربيه بالذات طيبه تسلم طيب
هالمره تقومين بتدور المعلمه القويه ليل
الارمله السيده المكافحه خمس بنات هل كنت
متحمسه لهذا الدور خاصه انه دور جديد في
مشوارك الفني هو بيني وبينك الدور كان
جديد عليا خالص من حيث المضمون والشكل وكل
حاجه يعني دي شخصيه انا ما لعبتهاش يعني
انا عملت اكثر من 120 فيلم ما عملتش
الشخصيه دي فاول ما جاني الورقه انا جاني
كذا ورق بس لقيت دي شدتني اكثر بالرغم
انها بعيد عن شخصيتي خالص بعيده عني خالص
فلقيت فيها يعني فيها ابعاد كثير للشخصيه
كبيره بالنسبه لي كممثله جديده بالنسبه لي
لجمهوري جديده بالنسبه لي شكلي لكل حاجه
يعني ست نفسي افهم بقى براحتي وسبت نفسي
اكل كل حاجه وقلت بقى خلاص
مره واحده يا يا استاذه ايوه
بالعكس ده تغيير
لو نرجع
نشوف الملك فريد شوقي الله يرحمه لما كان
بيعمل جان وبيضرب وفتوه ومش عارف ايه وجفت
اعمل الاب اللي
ده مطلوب للفنان حسب امكانيات الفنان نفسه
طيب السيده سهير مسلسل ام البنات يعتبر
عوده بعد غياب لماذا هذا الغياب اولا
بصي يا حبيبتي انا الغياب انا ما كانش
بكيفي لان انا مش عايزه برده ارجع ومجرد
ان انا ابقى متواجده وخلاص او موجوده في
دور بيقول اي كلام او موجود عشان استعرض
لا انا عايزه دور جديد بالنسبه لي فمكنتش
بلاقي كنت كان كل اللي بيجي لي ممكن تبقى
ام عاديه اخت
عاديه خاله ده ما يستهونيش انا كفنان ان
انا اعمله او او على الاقل مش يعني هحاسب
على مسيرتي الفنيه ان انا اقدم حاجه جديده
وحاجه كويسه فلما لقيت ام البنات ما فكرتش
يعني خلاص نزلت واشتغلت والحقيقه تعبنا
فيها قوي لان احنا كنا داخلين ورمضان بيجي
انت عارفه بسرعه فكنا بنشتغل انا مخلصه
تقريبا يوم اخر يوم يعني اول يوم رمضان
كنت مخلصه تصوير طب استاذه سهير يعني انت
ما فكرتيش في العمل دغري وافقتي بس ما صحت
انه كنت رفضتي عرض العمل في رمضان يعني
بالرغم من انه تم وضعه للخريطه رمضانيه
ليه لا هو ما كانش موضوع اول ما جيت اتفق
قالوا لي مش في رمضان عشان انا ما بشتغلش
في رمضان خالص خالص
فانا قلت لهم انا ما بصورش في رمضان لو
هتعملوه في رمضان انا مش هينفع اشتغل فهما
قالوا لا هنعم
له ان هو يتعمل في رمضان وانه ينزل في
رمضان وكده فالحمد لله ان انا خلصت قبل
رمضان بيوم يعني يوم صخور انا كنت مخلصه
شغلي ولماذا العوده العوده الفنيه بعد
غياب كانت من خلال دراما تلفزيونيه وليس
من خلال سينما مثلا
لا بصي السينما دي بقى دي عشقي فالسمه دي
عشان ارجع لها يرجع لها زي ما كنت نجمه
فيها وارجع بدرج حلو وشخصيه كبيره انما مش
مجرد في السينما وخلاص لا انما الدراما
التلفزيونيه ممكن تلاقي عندك القماشه
بتاعه ال 30 حلقه وال 15 حلقه هتتقدمي
فيها شخصيه انما في السينما عشان اطلع اخد
دور ولا لا ما ينفعش
طب يا استاذ سهير يعني يقول محمود درويش
في حضره الغياب حضور فهل الغياب لسنوات عن
الشاشه في صالح الفنان او النجم وهل
الغياب مبررات ايا كانت نوعها برايك
بصي هو هو الجياب وهو موجود على مكانه
كويسه يبقى يحتفظ بها هيفضل محتفظ بها
عايز يرجع يرجع على مكانه كويسه يا اما ما
يرجعش انا ده رايي يعني انا كفنانه انا
غبت بس عشان ارجع يرجع على مكانش اللي كنت
فيها وارجع بحاجه كويسه وحاجه جديده واحس
ان جمهوري يعني انا مش طالعه عشان استظرف
انا طالعه قد ما عمل فني لقيمه له كلمه
لومورال انما لمجرد تواجد لا انا ما انفعش
الفنان اللي يرجع لمجرد رجوع وعشان كده
انا بقول لك انا غبت كثير ورجعت وجبت
ورجعت عشان الاقي العمل اللي ممكن ارجع
بيه ترجعي في الوقت المناسب والمكان
المناسب دائما وشكرا ليكي شكرا لوقتك
ولوجودك ولظهورك معنا شكرا لكن من القاهره
عبر الهاتف فان القدير سهير رمزي لمتابعتي
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات